is now fire at the grill whether you are
a vegetarian or a vegan you can still
enjoy that summer barbecue and here with
some delicious grilling tips is diana
edelman the founder of vegans baby i'm
so excited to have you here so happy to
be here with you you are the pro at all
things veggies vegan you have really
developed this community within our
community tell us really quickly about
vegans babies and why you created it i
created vegans baby because i thought it
was going to be so hard to go vegan and
so i decided well i'm going to go vegan
i'm gonna show other people they can too
and you're not missing out on flavors or
anything like that so i just started it
six years ago as like a guide to show
people when they go out to eat like
here's where you can eat vegan and it
just kind of
blew up yeah
into all of this so it's been a wild
ride now we are into summer it's all
about barbecues and you don't have to
miss out if you are a vegan or a
vegetarian and you were just telling me
about this market that i didn't even
know existed in las vegas where you got
all this stuff from tell us about that
so this is vegging nut market they've
been opal a couple of years and it's an
all vegan grocery store it's on sunset
and eastern um you can get everything
you want and and just it just makes it
so much easier to be vegan you don't
have to go to the grocery store and go
like read all the ingredients and
everything everything here is vegan well
it makes it easy for everybody so let's
start at this end of the table what are
some items we have right here okay so i
feel like you know every every grilling
barbecue session you have to have the
burger so there's quite a few different
burgers nowadays we've got beyond which
is definitely leading the way in terms
of like vegan products right but then we
also have other things we have these
these are like full-on veggie burgers
for people that want something like
purely veg right and then we have over
here um light life makes burgers but
then if you kind of want to like change
it up a little bit there's a company
that makes vegan wings oh my gosh those
are delicious right pop them in the air
fryer there's also vegan shrimp nowadays
like it looks like shrimp it's coming
it's come so far what right if you just
showed me this i would think that this
is real shrimp let's plate that you can
still indulge in your favorites but
stick to your diet you know in your
location yeah there's also so this
company makes a skirt steak okay
it's insane insane and then we have here
amazed by this
spam okay oh my gosh pop this on the
grill and you've got grilled up vegan
spam you got a little bit of everything
you guys want and i want to move this
along this no no about a minute or so
but hot dogs here then you've got cheese
you can throw on the grill to make
burger vegan bacon you can grill up then
if you want to do corn yes right we've
got miyoko's butter which i'm obsessed
with is butter but you can smear it on
corn we've got
mayo so you can make your vegan potato
salad super easy right and then we have
desserts so you can use s'mores okay
vegan marshmallows ice cream which i may
or may not have already opened so tell
us what these are they look like
delicious they're vegan drumsticks
chocolate like chocolate coating vanilla
ice cream chocolate in the bottom of the
cone look at that close up so look at
how good that looks oh my gosh i love
dessert okay we have to wrap up i'm
gonna get this out of here but tell me
about our sauces over here these are the
sauces for the wings barbecue sauces and
then over here we've got these um
concentrate drinks so you can throw a
little vodka in them if you're an adult
or throw water in it have a nice
refreshing summer fruit juice and yeah
i didn't hear what you said because i'm
just trying to i'm just kidding this is
amazing
you can join in
and really quickly people want to find
you you're all over social media where
can people find you vegan's baby
everywhere across everything it's
vegan's baby
i try thank you so much cheers to summer
cheers to vegan dessert less guilt
that's what i'm saying